put the button on this conversation with
this lady right here oh yeah um does she
deserve to be on the cover yes or no no
absolutely not there's no agreement that
she should be on the cover i would say
i'll say no and i say the reason for
that is because what that is was that
the reason she's on there and not i mean
sports illustrated swimsuit edition made
its name on the fact that they've had
nothing but stunningly hot women on
there that were bikinis
that's the only reason most guys had a
subscription to sports illustrated in
the first place
yeah and so now it's kind of like um you
know uh putting her on there normalizes
the idea that beauty is because that's
the whole that's why peterson got in a
lot of hot water about this and he knew
damn well what he was doing he dropped
obama
okay so it's the normalization thing
because as i said statistically speaking
75 of the us population is overweight
but what it's also doing is it's saying
that beauty is actually objective and
not subjective and that's the problem
that you want to know why it's a
hypocrisy
outrage is because people say well you
know she's beautiful and and beauty's in
the eye of the beholder it's uh it's
subjective it's this like no it is not
let me let me that looks like a lane
brian ad well and then so what's what's
saying is that that beauty is a social
construct and it's like beauty is not a
social construct because if it were
think you know for for men you know men
have a larger you know pool of what
makes them you know aroused and
everything else but that the idea of
beauty like this is something that we
should promote in some you know as
opposed to something else that's saying
that social constructionism is is a
thing it's trying to reinforce social
construction is it fair to say that
jordan peterson is basically saying i
don't care how much you want to force
this down my throat she's not hot yeah
that's what it is look there's you know
i don't know we'll go the healthy right
we'll say oh well she's not healthy
that's not you know healthy she's a big
body positivity it's like that has
nothing like when i see that argument
i'm like i'm like don't go there yeah
just say this is based on social this is
on subjectivity and relativity as
opposed to empirical data and uh you
know objective realism let's look at
this let me ask you most men would not
find that attractive and just how jordan
peterson dropped a truth bomb out there
all right let's see what happens i don't
know if it was like you know yeah you
know trying to rattle the cage of the
people but
let's see if sports illustrated if they
knew what they were doing you know that
she wasn't the only one on the cover did
you guys know that so there were three
there were four different covers
so let's play no no one of them was
arguably the most famous woman in the
world kim kardashian
pulled that up
looks good controversial we can talk
about that
the third girl was ciara who's married
to quarterback russell wilson one
two-step music singer
and then how about this one
may musk do you know who this lady is
this is elon musk's mommy
no she's uh she was uh married to rick
okay she was just in the news not too
long trying to be a supermodel again how
old is that is she
just put in me i think she's about to be
70 something may
most age she looks better than the fat
girl she's the oldest she's 74 years old
yeah justin do you think she looks
better than the big girl yeah i think
she deserves it
really great yeah so hold on bro
hold on we're okay we're talking about
objective versus subjective that's good
some people are going to say look with
all due respect mr waller yeah i'd
rather have the bigger girl who's young
and hot than the old 74 year old lady
well i guess i guess if we're defining
the girl on the cover being a girl you
want to sleep with maybe yeah but as far
as deserves to be on there worked hard
to take care of herself her entire life
and eating fat yeah i put her in front
of the the latter the previous girls you
ladies and girls i respect this woman
more okay
that's what i'm saying you respect her
more yes absolutely
[Music]